The Joe Rogan experience.
Power is so scary, like that kind of power, the power,
and also the influence and sort of cronyism,
like being deeply attached to the criminal justice system for many,
many years over there being respected and being a part of this investigative
world where they're all the cops and they're all just like they know each other.
And you know, they look out for each other,
the fact that they didn't change their story.
Once they had all the DNA evidence with that Rudy guy,
and then it was all over it, they didn't go, okay,
we've made a mistake and instead they doubled down. And not only that,
but didn't go after him for the murder while they did,
but they didn't convict him of the murder, I should say. So what did they do?
So they convicted him of her rape because it was only his
DNA that was found inside of her body. And, um,
they convicted him of conspiracy to commit murder.
So basically taking part in a murder,
but not being the one to actually plunge the knife.
But this was a fabrication by the,
this is the prosecutor's idea that he was there with Raffaele and that you
guys held her down.
So they say that the scenario that my,
my prosecutor painted and he painted a few different scenarios because he
couldn't really like his imagination was going wild.
And there wasn't a lot of actual,
obviously there wasn't any evidence to support any of them,
but he kept thinking, okay, it's it's near it's the day after Halloween.
So maybe it's a satanic sexual ritual.
We know that there's some kind of sex thing involved.
We know that Amanda is like, well, we know,
we know that Amanda has sex with people.
So she's probably a sexually obsessed person.
And Meredith looked down on her for being a sexually obsessed person.
So what is likely to have happened in his brain is that I was hanging out with
Raffaele and Rudy Meredith comes home. She starts scolding me for my bad morals.
And then I'm like, you know what, we're going to rape you and kill you.
That's that's his scenario. And it's,
it's so unfortunate on so many levels because it's, I mean,
it says more about him than it says about anyone else that he would imagine that
that's just how people react to each other. Yeah.
Th this was not his initial idea though. Right? Was this as initial idea?
I mean, his initial idea was that I was involved somehow.
He didn't know how, but he thought that I was involved.
Somehow I knew something. I was covering up for someone.
And that's why he interrogated me for 53 hours over five days.
Which is really scary that they can do that. Right. It's like,
you can get someone to say a lot of things.
If you can get alone with them in a room, scare the out of them and,
and just torture them.
Well, I'm glad you,
you know that because like a lot of people don't know that you.
Can get people to crack. Oh.
Absolutely. Like that's, it's.
People crack when they get over by the cops for speeding. Oh yeah.
People crack for all kinds of things. They have a joint in their glove box.
People crack, you know, when, when authority is scaring,
you coming down on you and in your case,
it actually hit you a couple of times that there's, and you're 20.
Right?
20 Your brain isn't even fully formed.
My brain isn't fully formed. My friend had just been murdered.
I was alone in a foreign country.
And people were people who I was interesting. My life and safety too,
were screaming at me that I was wrong.
That I was never going to see my family again,
that I was super traumatized that I had.
I had seen something so horrible that I must have just completely blocked it
out. And here's, and here's a scenario that would explain that.
Look, you have a text message from your boss, Patrick Lumumba.
You must have met him that night. You must have seen him murder. Meredith.
Just admit it. Just admit it. Remember, remember,
remember I kept telling me like the gross thing about it was they kept telling
me to remember. They didn't even tell me to like, admit it.
They were telling me that I just couldn't remember it. And I had to remember,
or else I was never going to see my family again.
Jesus. So were you thinking,
you just had to tell them whatever they wanted to hear,
just so you could get out of there.
Honestly, I started to question my own sanity.
I started to believe them that I must have witnessed something horrible or,
and I just couldn't remember it.
And that's the only explanation for why they would treat me that way.
How long did that take before you think you started questioning your Saturday?
Um, so I was, you know,
a few hours into that final interrogation that was in the middle of the night.
I was not prepared to be interrogated at all because honestly they didn't even
call me in that night. They called my boyfriend Raffaele. Um,
but I was staying with him and I was afraid to be alone at home because a murder
was on the loose. And so I went with him and I was waiting in the,
um, in the lobby, like by the elevator,
waiting for him to come out from questioning. And then they brought me in, um,
and just went on and on and on. Um,
and so I cracked eventually. So the thing that cracked me too,
was they brought in an interpreter, right.
Someone who actually spoke English because for a long time,
I was just talking to people in Italian. And I was worried that I couldn't,
I wasn't even comprehensible.
I thought that the reason why they were yelling at me was because I was doing
something wrong. Like I just wasn't explaining myself correctly.
And then they put fluid where you.
Fluent, where you, I mean, I'd been there for like five weeks. So I.
Was a time before.
I had taken stallion for a year before. So I,
I was about as fluent as I like to say I had about the fluency of a
ten-year-old,
but I think that that's even generous because I could speak in certain tenses.
My vocabulary was totally limited though.
So there were limited things that I actually had the words to say.
And I remember even when I, um,
shortly after I was interrogated and signed the statements that they had written
up for me, I, they finally stopped yelling at me. They left me alone.
I had a moment to just like, be off to the side, quiet to myself.
And I was like, oh my God, what just happened? Everything is wrong.
This is all wrong. I need to tell them that it's all wrong. And I'd like,
I can't just go up in front of a jury right now and say,
this is the person who did it. I saw him do it. Like,
I don't actually remember that. And I told them, I need to tell you,
I need to tell you. And they were like, no, you'll remember,
don't worry about it. Like we don't, we don't need to talk anymore.
You'll remember just stay over there and keep remembering. And I was like, no,
I'm not remembering. I'm not remembering. And eventually I asked them like,
please give me a piece of paper because they weren't listening to me.
So I wrote on this piece of paper, I'm so confused. They were yelling at me.
Like, I don't, I don't, I can't actually testify to this. And I gave it to them.
And I was like, here's a gift because I didn't have the word for like,
here's my Rick recantation. I was just like, I'm giving this to you.
I need you to hear me. And they were like, okay, whatever,
we're taking you to jail, actually,
they didn't even tell me they were taking me to jail.
They th they were telling me that I was being taken to a holding place for my
own protection. And that I was an unimportant witness.
So they didn't tell you that you were being taken to jail because you were one
of the people that were accusing.
No, I was already in prison before I was ever actually told you are being,
you are suspected for the killing of Meredith Kertscher.
I was already in prison. How.
Long have you known this Meredith girl for.
A few weeks.
And you'd met her just because he had all moved there at the same time.
Yeah. So she had moved in before me, um,
but it was basically,
there were two rooms to let in this little house that was right next to the
university and we both happened to pick a flyer.
Um, and did you guys hang out a lot?
Did you know her well? Was she a good friend or she just someone you lived with?
Um, she was like a budding friend. Like we definitely hung out.
We would go to pizza together. I remember we went to like,
there's this famous chocolate festival.
That's improved HSA where they would like take huge refrigerator sized blocks of
chocolate and like carved them. Um, which was super cool. I'm very into that.
And we would go and check that out together. Um,
but we weren't like the best of friends.
Like she had a friend group of other young women from great Britain that
she hung out with a lot more than she hung out with me. Um,
but that isn't to say that we didn't go out dancing together or go out to dinner
together. We definitely did that.
The moment you found out that she had been murdered,
what was that like?
Um,
it's confusing because I knew that something
was wrong. As soon as I found,
like came home and I found that there was a window broken into and Meredith
wasn't answering her phone, but I didn't what was wrong.
I didn't, I didn't know.
And when the police came in and broke down her door and everyone started
screaming, I didn't see into her room. I never actually saw her body.
And so I didn't know what was going on.
I didn't know if that was Meredith in the room. In fact,
I remember at the first thing that Philomena,
one of my roommates started yelling was a foot, a foot. And I was like,
oh my God, is there like a severed foot in Meredith's room? Like,
I don't know what's going on.
She's Philomena is hysterical and I don't know what's going on.
Everyone's yelling and Italian speaking really quickly. I don't understand.
So I actually was relying on Raffaele to translate for me,
like what is going on? He was like, I don't know, let me, let me figure it out.
And we were all like shoved out of the house. And finally someone is like,
it's Meredith it's Meredith and she's dead. And I was like, oh my God.
Like it was outside of the house that someone was telling me she's her body was
in there. And someone told me that there was all this blood. Um,
I remembered not actually knowing like how she had died until I went
to the police office. And I asked, I was like being questioned.
And one of the police officers was like, and so like,
I sort of learned over the course of that day, these, the,
the details of it. But I didn't fully understand, like,
what had really happened. Like as far as I knew, you know, she, she,
some, I mean, it was clear that there was a break in,
like the window had been broken into. One of it was Filomena his room,
all of her stuff was all over the place.
It wasn't clear to me what had happened though.
And it wasn't until over the course of that whole day and piecing together what
I was hearing,
that I understood the gravity of the situation that she had been sexually
assaulted, that she had been stabbed to death, but it was a struggle.
Um, it was all, it was all like,
I remember the first thought and it's a guilty thought that I had. Um,
I remember thinking, thank God I wasn't home. Um,
because that could have been me and a part of me,
like over time felt really guilty about that thought,
because I thought maybe if I was home and there had been two of us,
maybe the outcome would have been different.
Maybe we would have been able to fend him off together,
but here's, you know, an athletic guy wielding a knife.
I'm not sure that we would have, and maybe I would have been dead too.
So it's kind of a thought that comes back to mind a lot.
When I think about this, um, and how fortuitous it was, um,
that I just happened to be in this like brand new romance and hanging
out with my new boyfriend all the time, every waking moment that I could.
And that's what happened.
It's hard for me to imagine the jolt
of a 20 year old life where
you are overseas going to school
involved in this new romantic relationship.
And then out of nowhere, boom,
you're a suspect in a murder.
Yeah. Well, and what's interesting is, I didn't know, like,
I didn't know that I was a suspect is like the boom for me was someone close to
me just died and that could have been me. And.
And then it was all those things that piled on. They got piling on.
Yeah. And then, you know, I'm in jail, I'm thinking, oh my God,
this is all just a horrible misunderstanding. Like the,
I'm sure they're going to figure it out sometime. Um,
I remember like the first two years of my imprisonment,
I was convinced that it was all just a big misunderstanding and somebody would
figure it out. And I was convinced, I was,
I was convinced that there was no possible way that people
could actually believe that I was involved.
Like even just not because it's me,
but because there wasn't any evidence there,
like it was so patently obvious to me that like this, this idea of me,
this Foxy Knoxy character that was being constructed and in the courtroom,
this Lucifer arena,
like this idea of a person was obviously made up.
It was so obvious to me and yet, and,
and.
Yet it didn't seem like the Italian media just ran with it though.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
And that was one of the big sort of regrets that might,
especially my family had, was at the very beginning. Um,
they were advised to not speak to the media at all because they were just going
to make a field day of it. There was, you know,
in the same way that there was never going to, once I was accused,
there was never going to be anything that I could do to prove my innocence in
the eyes of people. Um,
my lawyers were also worried that there was nothing my family could say,
but that would not be twisted and turned into something that would just
fuel further fuel the scandal mongering.
And what that meant was there was a void, there was a void in which,
who I was,
my very identity could be reconstructed or constructed out of
total fantasy.
That was the only thing that was that the only reason why
it was being constructed was to further the scandal and to sell more papers like
that. That was the reason why the,
it wasn't the public interest of the story that kept the sun in,
in Britain reporting on this case. Like they were,
they were reporting like reporting on whether or not I ate pizza,
like the days leading up to my arrest like that. It's just selling papers.
Watch the entire episode for free, only on Spotify.